se faire vacciner en plein air et au son
d'un pot au traditionnel de quoi
détendre
alicia j'étais anxieuse mais en arrivant
ici
le fait de voir des gens danser chanter
c'est merveilleux on se sent comme à la
maison
mission réussie pour cette clinique de
vaccination éphémère sur ce thème ici on
offre une sécurité culturelle dit-il
on crée un endroit où les gens se
sentent chez eux il existe encore des
billets dangereux à l'égard des
autochtones au sein du système de santé
selon lui stephen keynes connais des
gens qui ont demandé des soins médicaux
est automatiquement des médecins leur
demander s'il était ivre ou avait
consommé de la drogue qu'ils étaient
juste malade dit il ici les membres des
premières nations les métis et inuits de
toronto ont pu recevoir première ou
deuxième dose du vaccin pfizer
administrés par des professionnels issus
de leur communauté
sensibiliser les autochtones à la
vaccination dans des grandes villes
comme toronto n'est toutefois pas facile
notamment parce que la population est
dispersée nous sommes plus de 95 milles
autochtone à toronto dit elle et
malheureusement nous subissons encore
souvent un traitement différent lorsque
nous allons à l'hôpital notre problème
ajoute les médecins c'est que bien
souvent ces communautés sont fichés de
manière disproportionnée par la pauvreté
et la précarité et au fait qu'elle n'a
pourtant pas été évident de faire
avancer la vaccination des autochtones
dans les villes rappelle le député la
provence
ayant d'abord prioriser les communautés
éloignées pour les 1001 c'était en tout
cas une sortie en famille réussies
rachel se dit heureuse d'avoir vécu
cette expérience
mais surtout elle a hâte de pouvoir
enfin bientôt serrer ses grands parents
dans ses bras ici cammy fei raizen radio
canada
photo non